hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone to so many questions on this
week's Game of Thrones QA these dudes
are kind of back to normal after Comic
Con the big news right now is actually
the kid Harrington was seen in Belfast
again we're on like Kit Harington hair
watch again I don't think that's really
big news I don't think it becomes like
really big news until he's seen in
Belfast for a long period of time or
like really deep in this season remember
he signed on to a big movie this summer
and he hasn't gone off and filmed that
yet so there will be a period when he is
definitely not around like he'll have to
go shoot that movie at a certain point
if he comes back to Belfast after that
then that's pretty big news just
remember whether he comes back to life
on the show or whether he stays dead
there there are just like so many
different ways that they could play with
that on the show his whereabouts don't
factor in quite as much as say like the
other actors that have to be on screen
all the time so here we go on to
questions just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen all of season five yet
Kaz asks for the QA do the red priest
other than Melisandre like Thoros have
to sacrifice people in order to increase
their powers or is it just her well
Melisandre is a little bit different
from some of the other red priests and
that she's a shadow binder like not all
the red priests are shadow binders they
haven't fully explained it in the books
yet but the way I view it is is that
something needs to be offered to the red
God something to appease him and usually
when Thoros has done it someone has died
already so you could view that as an
offering Thoros isn't just like walking
around trying to resurrect people on the
side of the road it's usually only after
something really tragic happens but you
know like when beric Dondarrion does
something heroic it ends up dying he
died in a tournament he died fighting
the mountain all things that you could
view is being sacrificed were the events
and eventually he even started
worshipping the red God himself so I
think of Melisandre we're gonna try and
resurrect Jon Snow then the offering has
already been made just because he's
lying there bleeding out next question a
VX it sounds like they're casting some
of the northern Lords like the Mander
leaves and umbers for season six do you
think they'll rally behind San sir john
and defeat the Bolton's well you know I
I don't know you know beyond Sansa who's
going to be running around in the North
fighting the Bolton's but I definitely
think the northern Lords will start
working against them the writers kept
beating us over the head with
that the North remembers line over and
over at Winterfell the north is just
going to continue to remember in various
tabby ways throughout season six the
Bolton's have a really huge army so I
wouldn't be surprised if people start to
whittle away at that like the other
northern Lords start to whittle away at
that over the course of season six next
question Mindless asks do you think the
equates will appear again to guide Danny
in season six I believe she's a more
important role to play in Danny's story
line well there is like a new red
priestess that they're trying to cast
for season six I don't think that's
quite but I think that that new person
will fill that role what I mean to say
is I think this new red priestess will
be a new advisor for generis but just
speaking about book quaid no I don't
think that we're going to see her again
on the show the books are a different
story though I definitely think that
she's going to appear again in the books
next question James asks i know the
show's only contracted through seven
seasons but since it's such a success do
you think the showrunners would consider
extending the length actually the
showrunners have like a pretty hard
expiration date in terms of story like
they pretty clear that they don't want
to go to like 10 seasons just because
they can add its current burn rate the
show will get through all the books
stuff by the end of season seven unless
they adjust a little bit HBO itself
wants to keep it around as long as
possible so so if anyone is going to try
and keep it going for longer it's gonna
be corporate HBO I'm sure a lot of the
actors would love to continue doing the
show but there are so many of them and
some of them are really starting to blow
up like look at Emilia Clarke for
instance like she's starting to do
really big mainstream Hollywood movies
she's not going to stick around forever
it's just when you have so many young
actors it's hard to keep them around for
longer than seven or eight seasons just
because their career starts to take off
and it's really hard for them to take
other opportunities whenever they're
bound to a show even if it is only like
ten episodes of season I think the most
realistic solution is that they just
sort of spin off during the final season
of the show and it would be with a
completely different cast Walking Dead
is kinda in the same situation where
it's like you know we have this main
show we think we can keep it going
through 12 seasons but but you never
know what's going to happen with the
cast they might decide to leave so we
need a spin-off show to hedge our bets
so if anything they'll continue to be a
song of ice and fire content on
TV but you know maybe not in its current
form beyond season 7 next question rad
asks are all worthy Targaryen fireproof
like Danny Jon Snow got burned while
fending off a white on the first season
and I'm not sure if that throws a wrench
in our plus l equals J like you're
saying you know if John is a Targaryen
then how did he get burned that's
actually a myth that Targaryens can't be
burned there's a really big event called
a tragedy at summerhall where a bunch of
targets died in a fire there was even a
Targaryen King that tried to drink
wildfire because he thought he was
literally a dragon as you know as in
blood of the Dragon so no Targaryen scan
totally burn just like anybody else the
reason that Daenerys did not burn is
because they were using blood magic so
Jon Snow getting burnt has has
absolutely nothing to do with Targaryen
blood next question March one asks if
Amon is keeping tight notes would it be
possible for Santa discover them before
going to the Citadel if so would he tell
John well well Sam has already gone to
the Citadel so he wouldn't be able to
tell John even if there were notes I I
think that if Sam's gonna find anything
out at the Citadel it's going to be
techniques for fighting White Walkers
based on some of the shooting sets in
like the like the tower a joy video that
I just did it it seems like if the show
is going to confirm who Jon Snow's
parents are it's gonna be using some
sort of flashback mechanism but that
says nothing about what george RR martin
is going to do in the books you know
avenged eventually he probably will
reveal who Jon Snow's parents are in
either wins a winter or a dream of
spring he could use some piece of
Correspondence left over from when
Rhaegar was still alive we would
flashbacks would be like I'd like a
thousand times more fun though next
question Jon Snow asks what do you think
will happen once John has been brought
back will he leave the Nights Watch and
charged to Winterfell or head somewhere
else well if you remember he was trying
to get everyone to go to Winterfell
originally so I think you know if he
came back everyone would probably just
be like oh you know he has a good point
let's listen to him there's very clearly
a white Walker army marching on us it
really wouldn't make sense for John to
just like turning around and murder all
those stabby Nights Watch people just
because they need every single body they
can get there already dramatically
undermanned even with all the wildlings
so to turn around and kill half of his
existing army would just be the
terrible terrible thing to do that is of
course assuming that he's resurrected
and he still wants to fight the White
Walkers in all evidence points to that
being the case so I don't think he's
going to turn around and stab everyone
if he kills anyone when he comes back it
would be like Alliser thorne that would
be a lot of fun you guys can actually
let me know whether you agree or not
would it be more satisfying to see John
come back to life and then immediately
chop Alastair thorns head off or to see
Alliser thorne bend the knee to John and
say you were right the whole time I'm
sorry next question bill tang asks now
that we get to see the Dothraki hordes
again with Danny would you please do
more Dothraki videos so just to answer
some does rocky questions I think it's
pretty clear that Daenerys is going to
like wow them with the Dragons Emilia
Clarke has said that she's read a couple
scripts and she saw something like
mind-blowing thing coming it probably
has something to do with her storyline
in one really easy way to win over a
giant army is with like a flaming dragon
flying through the sky like a meteor it
feels like Denarius only has a couple
options in the east right now she can
either get everyone to bend the knee or
she can go on another campaign of
conquest which would be really long and
really drawn out and it seems like the
series is trying to push her to Westeros
by the final season and a big protracted
campaign would take way longer than that
so I think is the Dragons continue to
grow the legend of Daenerys will grow
and and she'll win more followers over
she won't have to go around roasting
every single city that she meets so just
plan on Denarius getting a really large
Dothraki Army before the end of season
six next question Joanna asks do you
think that will finally get to see Ed
mirror and the blackfish again next
season or are they forever at sea with
Gendry I would say number two they're
probably not coming back ednor the actor
that plays ed mirror is on Outlander
right now he's playing the villain he's
a blackjack I think is his name he is
really terrible villain so it's funny to
go back and watch his game of thrones
scenes no I don't think they'll be back
there are a lot of storylines all over
Westeros that have seemingly been
dropped you know throughout the the five
seasons I think before we get like our
final episode in our final season
they'll at least touch base on some of
the running storylines that seemingly
have no conclusion the show will at
least try to address all the important
stuff but don't be wildly
surprised if you never see him again
next question no asks could you make a
video about where the hell Rickon is
maybe some predictions as to whether or
not he'll be involved in season six well
we actually know where Rickon is he's on
the Isle of ska go sits by
eastwatch-by-the-sea hiding out with
OSHA the show might put him with one of
the other northern Lords just hiding out
some some people who are still loyal to
the Starks in terms of the actor coming
back on the show proper I don't think
that we'll see him again until he's
useful for the narrative and it as of
right now he's not that useful because
Sansa still alive if Santa were to die
then Rickon would be the next in line
like the next stark left alive and if
people knew about that they would try to
keep him safe till he was old enough to
try and take back Winterfell it'd be
like a tangent storyline for young Griff
in the books like that that type of
narrative where he just he hides out for
a number of years till he's old enough
to rally a force behind him but based on
the amount of time that we have left on
the show I i don't think that Rickon is
going to be of any use to anyone so just
do not plan on seeing Rickon again on
the show at least before the finale I'm
sure if Sansa work to ever retake
Winterfell then she would go looking for
Rickon thank you so much though everyone
for so many questions is there always a
ton of fun to do oh you know hopefully I
answered most of the big questions I
think everyone's still kind of on Kit
Harington hair watch so we're all
wondering what's going on with that
they're going to be shooting game of
thrones all the way through november i
think you know through the end of the
year so there's still a lot of stuff to
come congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner to jacqueline lamb you
in a twenty-dollar amazon gift card just
be sure to message me on the back end of
my channel so i can get your contact
info next week's giveaway will start
whenever I post my Knicks game of
Thrones bonus video that's probably
going to be something from Jaime
Lannister's history just because I
haven't talked about him in a little
while I feel like what's happening with
Marcela right now it's going to drive
him in a really interesting direction
especially considering what search he's
doing in King's Landing if there are any
other bonus videos that you guys want me
to do just leave your requests in the
comments below so just in case you guys
haven't seen it I just did a video kind
of explaining the Tower of joy and why
everyone's going so crazy about it in
season six in the show right now you can
click here to watch that and you can
click here to learn all about Arthur
Dayne thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you